larry king sat down with the most famous
people in the world
but you know he was just as big a star
as they were
that was the magnitude of his impact
well absolutely and now many of those
famous folks are honoring
one of the greatest talk show hosts of
all time i had no great wish for
celebrity i had no great wish for fame
but i did have a wish to communicate the
television legend passed away early
saturday at cedars-sinai medical center
after a battle with covid 19.
the 87 year old reportedly contracted
the virus from a home health care worker
i'm by nature a curious elf i'm just
interested in people i listen to their
answers and i ask questions
the guy was so strong and he was
he was the one i looked up to so much
about live broadcasting
from ryan seacrest to oprah stars paid
tribute
i just spoke to suzanne summers who was
a frequent guest on larry's show
and a close friend what would you say
would be larry's greatest
legacy larry king could talk
to anyone about anything when larry was
hospitalized three weeks ago
suzanne feared the worst i was kind of
expecting it
his health has been bad the last several
years and
every time i would see him he was
thinner and thinner and then he's had
um so much sadness in the last few years
you know having two children die within
a short period of one another
larry was definitely a fighter and had
his share of health battles he had a
stroke in march of 2019 and was in a
coma for a week
but that wasn't his first close call
years ago i had quintuple bypass surgery
10 years later i had angioplasty in one
of the veins that had closed off
anybody who's had bypass surgery in a
heart attack thinks about mortality a
lot
five months after his stroke larry made
headlines by filing for divorce from
wife shawn
after 22 years of marriage e.t covered
the couple from when they first wed in
1997
of course larry handled their 26-year
age difference
with his trademark sense of humor when
did you know i was the final one larry
[Laughter]
when you when you think you have
arthritis it better be the final one
because there's nothing left
larry and sean had two sons together
chance and cannon
larry was in his 60s when the boys were
born once there was an
airplane airplane airplane
today chance is 21 and canon 20 years
old
along with their 59 year old half
brother larry king jr
they released a statement honoring their
father quote
we are heartbroken over our father's
death and together
with our extended family mourn his
passing the world knew larry king is a
great interviewer
but to us he was dad we will miss him
every single day of our lives larry was
worth a reported 50 million dollars
and was also known as quite the ladies
man he was married
eight times and fathered five children
e.t attended his 1989 nuptials to wife
number six
julie alexander but the marriage only
lasted three
years the public is much much less
curious
over a relationship of mine than they
are
over a relationship of tom cruise
a broadcasting legend larry did over 7
000 shows on cnn
and interviewed some 30 000 guests brad
pitt
did you offer him your house for a
honeymoon uh
no but i will now you're you know you
can come here
want more children oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah we're just getting started you're
not the average american woman megan
admit it
well i would like to think that i i
okay she's terrific i liked her very
very smart
his career spanned six decades our mary
hart was a close friend
he told her this secret about getting
his start in the business
do you remember it vividly larry vividly
i'm on the air and i couldn't think of a
thing to say and the
station manager kicked open the door and
said speak
through all his success and fame larry
remained humble and grateful for the
work that enriched his life
i think the most fortunate thing in my
life is to have known and interviewed
great people
it's a hell of a job larry knew
how to bring out those special moments
and interviews
he will be missed